Salut, aujourd'hui je vous parle depuis Mulhouse où je joue une dernière fois ce soir à l'Entrepot.
Et aujourd'hui c'est le jour du Master Class.
Depuis quelques jours que l'on discute ensemble sur les réseaux sociaux, vous me demandez quels livres il faut lire pour devenir mentaliste.
Pour pouvoir mentaliser !!!
Ce Master Class sera dédié à comment devenir mentaliste, mais il faudrait d'abord avoir une vraie définition de ce qu'est un mentaliste.
Qu'est ce que le mentalisme ? Chaque mentaliste a sa propre définition, la mienne est la suivante :
C'est un mot fourre-tout, c'est un mot pratique dans lequel on met tout ce que l'on veut.
Ça a frappé ou pas ?
Ah oui ça a frappé.
Yo ? Ça va mec ?
Je suis en train de faire la vidéo de demain. C'est Ludo !!! C'est lui qui fait la régie ici !!!
Non c'est vrai ça filme ? Ouais si c'est vrai ça filme
Je vous disais donc avant que Ludo me coupe c'est donc un mot fourre-tout dans lequel on met un petit peu ce que l'on veut.
Pour moi le mentalisme c'est un mélange de psychologie, d'influence, de technique de magicien, de mémoire, de calcul hyper rapide...
Chacun met ce qu'il veut. La question n'est pas comment devenir mentaliste mais qu'est ce que vous aimez dans le mentalisme et comment vous pouvez apprendre ça ?
Il y a des formations qui existent sur le mentalisme, il y a aussi des livres qui existent dessus.
Personnellement j'y crois pas trop surtout les formations, les livres je les ai lus, j'ai souvent été déçu.
C'est plutôt des succès commerciaux sur le mot mentalisme.
Je pense que si vous identifiez ce qui vous plait vraiment dans le mentalisme vous pouvez alors vous former à ces techniques là précisément.
En général, ce qui vous plait le plus, c'est ce que l'on appelle le langage non verbal, la communication non verbale,
le fait de pouvoir déduire des choses.
Pour commencer je vous recommande deux livres qui sont des best-sellers qui existent au format poche, qui sont pas trop chers.
C'est pas du placement de produit !!!
Le premier c'est : "Ces gestes qui vous trahissent" de Joseph Messinger. Messinger quoi...
C'est une bête de pavé sur l'interprétation des gestes. Très interessant, très fourni,
Des fois ça enfonce un petit peu des portes ouvertes. On se dit: "Bah oui mais ça ça ça me parait évident."
Et c'est vrai que l'on a tous l'intuition d'interpréter ça par contre on ne prend pas forcément le temps d'analyser réellement la personne en face de l'autre.
Donc c'est très très bien. Vous apprendrez des choses dedans c'est sûr. C'est un petit peu une bible dans le domaine.
Deuxième livre incontournable, c'est celui de Paul Ekman qui s'appelle "Je sais que vous mentez !".
Le titre c'est un petit peu comme les liens Internet, ce que l'on appelle les "putaclic".
Là c'est pas une "putaclic", mais bon c'est un titre très vendeur "Je sais que vous mentez !".
Quand vous aurez fini de lire ce livre quand vous aurez assimilé tout ce qu'il y a marqué, vous ne serez pas un spécialiste du mensonge du tout.
En fait, c'est pas tellement la vocation du livre. Par contre vous allez apprendre un nombre incroyable de techniques
Il a surtout des approches très particulières, c'est lui  qui les a écrites, c'est lui qui les a trouvées.
Elles sont extrêmement intéressantes. C'est un grand grand spécialiste Paul Ekman.
D'ailleurs ils se sont inspirés de lui pour faire Lightman, dans Lie to Me.
Dans ce bouquin, on passe en revue plein de choses: les mots, les intonations, les gestes, les micros expressions...
Il y a beaucoup de ces techniques qui ont été reprises par le FBI et la CIA.
C'est pour moi un incontournable que ce soit pour débuter ou pour se perfectionner.
Alors évidemment si pour vous mentalisme c'est autre chose, c'est la mémoire dans ce cas là, je vous conseille de vous tourner sur des livres sur la mémoire.
Pour ça tous les livres de Dominic O'Brien sont vraiment excellents.
Si ce qui vous intéresse le plus dans le mentalisme c'est l'hypnose ou la mise en transe, alors faites une vraie formation d'hypnose, d'hypnothérapeute ce serait encore plus intéressant.
Si c'est la graphologie qui vous intéresse, achetez des bouquins sur la graphologie ou faites des formations, ça aussi il y en a.
Vous voyez où je veux en venir ? Détectez exactement ce qui vous intéresse dans votre notion du mentalisme ou votre fantasme du mentalisme,
et formez vous précisément à ces techniques là et lisez précisement sur ces techniques là, plutôt que d'essayer d'acquérir un savoir trop généraliste.
Faites les choses étape par étape et ça marchera beaucoup mieux.
Voilà, je pense que c'est le Master Class le plus court que l'on ai fait mais peut être aussi un des plus intéressant.
Vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo, puisque de toute manière je lis tous les commentaires.
Et si cette vidéo là vous a plu, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air !!!
Pensez également à vous abonner avant de quitter cette vidéo, n'oubliez pas qu'à 50 000 abonnés on se fait un truc de ouf que j'ai annoncé dans la vidéo n°100 !!!
Demain c'est dimanche donc je vous apprends un truc de mentalisme pour bluffer les gens donc rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !!!